DAVID WEITZ: When you eat food, there's
much more to food than just the taste.
In addition to the taste,
there's the texture,
the way the food feels in your mouth.
As a good example, this
steak that we have here.
We're going to cook the steak, and
I'm going to show you how it feels--
how the way it feels
changes when you cook it.
What that means is when
you chew on the steak, how
it feels when you chew on it changes.
That's the texture.
That's the mouthfeel.
And that's determined by
the elasticity of the steak.
The elasticity of the
steak will increase
as it becomes more difficult to chew as
we cook it for a longer period of time.
So all foods have a texture.
All foods have a mouthfeel.
If you don't like steak, for example, if
you prefer tofu if you're a vegetarian,
it too comes in different flavors.
It comes in different styles.
You can get a firm tofu
or you can get soft tofu.
A firm tofu takes more force
from your mouth to chew it.
It's more elastic.
It's stiffer.
A soft tofu is much softer.
It's much easier to chew.
And when you're finished the steak
and your tofu, you have dessert.
You have chocolate.
It too comes with different textures.
Chocolate mousse-- it's light.
It's airy.
It's very easy to chew.
It's a very low elastic material.
The elasticity of chocolate
mousse is very low.
If you take a chocolate
bar, it's stiffer.
It takes more force to chew it.
It's elasticity increases.
And if you take real chunk chocolate,
a really good Belgian chocolate,
it's much stiffer.
You have to bite much harder.
So the mouthfeel, how it tastes, all is
wrapped up in the elasticity of a food.
And this is how we characterize
what the mouthfeel of a food is.
So if we want to measure it, we
have to measure the elasticity.
And let's start with
the very simplest thing.
Let's start with a spring.
Here I have a spring, and I can hang
a weight on the end of the spring.
If I hang a weight on the end of
the spring, the spring lengthens.
It becomes longer.
It becomes longer by a certain amount.
That amount-- that delta L-- the change
in length is determined by how stiff,
by how elastic, the spring is
and how large the weight is.
So let me hang the weight on it.
The spring gets longer,
but then it stops moving.
The forces are balanced.
There's no longer a net
force on the spring.
The spring is exerting a
force to hold the weight up,
and the weight is exerting a
force to stretch the spring.
We can do the same thing if
instead of lengthening the spring,
we compress the spring.
We put the weight on top
of the spring like this.
If you push on the spring
and you push it down,
then the spring pushes upwards.
It pushes in the opposite direction.
It tries to bring itself
back to its original length.
And we can write the
relationship between the force
of the spring and the change
in the length of the spring.
It's called Hooke's Law.
And it just says that
the force is linearly
proportional to the change in length.
This minus sign arises because
there is always a restoring force.
The spring is always trying
to retain its original length.
It's trying to get longer,
if you're compressing it.
And it's trying to get shorter,
if you're extending it.
The relationship between the
change in length and the force
is the spring constant,
and that determines
the elasticity of the spring.
The larger the spring constant
is, the more of the force
it takes to extend it by a given length.
So a stiff spring has a
very large spring constant,
and it takes a larger
force to extend it.
We can use the same concept
now to describe food.
In the case of food,
we have some object.
For example, we have
this piece of steak.
We want to measure the
elasticity of a piece of steak.
The force that we put on the food--
the force that we put on the steak--
will depend on the size of the steak.
So if I take a very large piece
of steak, and I want to deform it.
I want to squeeze it.
I want to change its
thickness by a certain amount.
It takes a much larger force than
if I take a small piece of steak.
But when I tell you what the
elasticity of the steak is,
I don't want to have the dimensions
of the object, of the piece of steak,
as part of the elasticity.
So I want to somehow take out
the dimensions of the steak.
So to do that, I take the
force and I normalize the force
by the area on which I apply the force.
That gives me the stress.
The same point, I don't want to know how
thick the steak is when I compress it.
I just want to know how much I
compress it for a given thickness.
So I take the compression--
I take the change in thickness,
as I squeeze on the steak,
and I normalize it by
the original length.
And that gives me a strain.
A strain is the relative
change in length.
Now I can calculate the elastic
constant in the same way
that I calculated the spring constant.
I want to calculate a spring
constant, I take a force
and then divide it by
a change in length.
For the elastic constant
of the steak, I take
the stress, which is the
force divided by the area,
and I divide that by the strain, which
is the relative change in length.
And that gives me the
elastic constant of the food.